advice on restarting your life after the
military I think you just got to figure
out what you want to do yeah you got to
figure out I have a new monster that I
tell people now it's it's uh find your
next mission I got really lucky because
we got right into this but I I would
disagree with you there in that it
wasn't that we got lucky right in that
and that if you think about what we're
doing now this is what we like to do uh
we brought lessons back for Modi that we
uh we translated and gave to the next
generation of seals and and saw the
impact that was happening I mean when
you when you came back from high you
could have had any job that you wanted
to and you said I want to go run
training attachment because I want to
make sure that the the next uh seals
that are coming through this training
and going forward to places like Iraq
and Afghanistan are ready uh and this is
this is what I like to do and and I'm
gonna figure out a way to do something
that is useful it impacts people uh and
I think that's that's rookie is finding
that next mission for sure